um
season one
rest species episode six today hey toss
a coin to that like button while you're
at it that's a coin to that subscribe
button while you're at it toss many
coins to our patreon page where we have
the full length watch alongs where you
sync up with the time code for witcher
we do many shows over there with the
same ticket the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
wouldn't you know also thanks to the
boys of red pepper for helping setting
down these highlights almost caught up
with the series three more episodes and
then we're ready for season two while
panicking with covering spider-man no
way home because they're releasing it
all around the same time hell yeah gonna
be a busy weekend let's get to it
[Music]
let's get on before the beast gets
hungry again but we made a deal we made
a deal with a living wager no sense in
hanging around to pay a dead one
he's not dead ye of little faith sorry
who are you
move along
old man do as the bard asks or i'll be
forced to draw my weapons what weapons
those weapons i see no steel here
that escalated quickly
what the hell
i am porch three jackdaws these are my
companions tear and
i've been looking for you geralt of
rivia
what
they're going to wakanda a short while
ago a green dragon landed across the
border in king nedemier's mountains now
the king is in a bind he's commissioned
a hunt to kill it the winner gets the
dragon treasure horde plus the title of
lord over one of his new vassal state
nice
you have the most incredible neck
like a sexy goose
smooth
i want you to join my team
team
geralt a team player usually they save
that for the sequel
you can barely manage his hype boy
that's only three where's the what's the
fourth team
them
oh oh oh
friendly competition so much it's been
very nice thank you for the wine and the
pies but as the man said we really can't
get involved carol oh he's going to say
yes
oh yeah
jennifer's the sexy goose
[Laughter]
what are you doing here again i'm here
with my escort
noble sir i continuously to assist him
in killing the dragon
for kingdom and glory
how quickly is he going to die
oh oh my
hello little fellow
oh aren't you just the cutest
most
terrifying whoa
oh my
what in the name of bowman mark desert
santa ricker it's probably starving
she's your weapons
what a dick dude
yeah no
oh
to hell with you
nah he's being noble and [ __ ]
what an [ __ ]
oh oh my god what an [ __ ]
it was kind of tasty though
well let's get some let's try some don't
knock it so you try it
damn
oh my god yes [ __ ] your pants you
[ __ ] i escort you to your tent
will you be joining me
my lady i would never degrade your honor
in such a way jeepers i hate to break it
to you but that ship has sailed wrecked
and sung for the bottom of the ocean
[Laughter]
[ __ ] green dragons they're the most
common red dragons less so black dragons
are the rarest gold dragons are
rarest the old dragons permit huh
they're gonna chemical dragon
keep walking the nilf guardians could be
anywhere we're not safe yet how did you
escape the attack mal sac thor please
don't ask valid questions
who slits a man's throat while he's
relieving his bowels
there's nothing sacred anymore ah
good i'm here for the dragon there are
certain healing properties it's rumored
to possess do not tell me you've
traveled all this way
for made-up fertility cures using fresh
dragon hearts they're not made up
you
my mother do you think i'd make a bad
one
definitely
i'd rather use my child surprises brooks
abate than subjected to this life what
did she just say oh no
you have a child surprise
you lecture me on made-up cures for
having a child
meanwhile you cheat with destiny to
steal one
every time i'm near you i say more than
five minutes than i've said in weeks i
know i love it
i've had enough of you suck stop our
name is not much suck
he killed mouse suck and took his
disgusting form to find you
no
no tara let him live don't let dora die
oh yeah
hey there
we prefer it like this anyway
what is that like pure silver or
something
oh real form let's see it yeah
where are you taking us who wants them
the man with the winged helmet why is he
going to so much trouble i'm special i
don't know how or why but there's
something inside me
kill him
what
then i'll do it whoa no no no lag
we're very close how can you possibly
know that it's a perfectly fine route
for dwarf ah
stifle your mule in your manage as long
as you don't look down
we must make it to the minds of mormon
speak friend don't enter
oh no
get it first going to fall at some point
i really didn't think you would meet his
fate here he will save us yet but first
you must let go
no
you're out
the planks won't hold thank you
[Music]
wow i really didn't
think i'd be right about it
yo
um
[Music]
oh so they bumped into each other a
bunch
a lot of intervening
encounters
[Music]
they are so beautiful both of them yeah
it's a shame neither of them can have a
kid
[Music]
yeah
toss a groin to your
[Laughter]
oh valley of horny
[Music]
before we met
the days were calm and the nights were
restless
but now
you're important to me
wow
words jessica has been waiting here for
a long time
poor guy
he's listening outside and weeping
[Music]
i made you accidentally hey again
you're so
it could oj
needy witcher
[Laughter]
good morning
yes my man
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's that guy yeah
never takes off his helmet that guy
oh never mind he took off his
you are head key to everything cyrilla
you must be starving
oh
[Laughter]
whoa
nice
wow
and they keep the wind going still
it is a green dragon
no closer
what
oh
[ __ ]
zag a gold dragon
is that a gold dragon yeah looks like it
so witcher and his sorceress
hello again
what
what are they telling me right here he
is he's the dragon
so we had to keep our enemies close so i
came to find you
the white-haired witcher
the knight who was taught to save
dragons instead of kill
them oh
take them on dude let's do it
boho it's mine
[Music]
oh man that is just
so sexy mr and mrs smith over here
go
i'll protect the egg you're a dragon do
some dragon [ __ ] he's fire
step on a couple of them
[Music]
no
it's not going to happen
yeah
there we go
assume you don't get to see me crack
that egg
how did he become a formidable foe i
have no idea
just by the sheer power being an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what that [ __ ] shite we miss a whole
motherload of fun huh
his vest
scales yeah
oh nice i pulled my back teeth out
tell the king if he's not satisfied he
can expect the body of a dragon dropped
upon his royal wedding
free of charge
where's dara yeah he's back there
somewhere
if i stay with you any longer i'll be
dead too no
i'm done apologizing i'm done with all
of this i have to move on
okay yeah okay
i hope you're right princess
what's your next move
find a new family what the hell i can't
be that for you anymore
oh come on man
not cool dude nah he's just all on his
feelings he'll be back he's too good a
guy def patel would have made a great
older version of you
i can see why get out didn't want to
lose you
does that mean
[Music]
the gym
that's why we can't escape each other
why i feel this way inside
it's not because of anything real
no
ah [ __ ]
you made a wish it's magic it's real
yeah how could we ever know
well you have the feeling now might as
well just roll with it yeah
go with it
sorceress will never regain her wound
though you didn't want to lose her
geralt
you will
ha ha what
he already has
oh
if life could give me one blessing it
would be to take you
off my hands
hey right then no
oh i'll go get the rest of the story
from the others
see you around carol i have to walk down
the mountain together
he's just going to walk really far apart
gather the men
we cannot fail him
the time of the sword in the axe is nigh
hmm
i fully get what's going on there at the
end
yeah
definitely
oh i have no questions so fully get it
good you can you can fill me in i'm that
good
ladies and gentlemen i love this show i
love it quite a bit
it's enjoyable
enjoyable like nobody's business
john did you enjoy it i enjoyed it i
felt like i was on an adventure
i feel i feel like it was on an inventor
with the wet shower
yeah man that guy was like the standout
performer of the episode he had so much
gusto
these episodes are so adventurous i and
so sprawling and each episode feels
um like they capture so much
and especially when they do time jumps
with episodes not just different
timelines
i don't know how i could really
most of you guys watch this in one go
and for me like this plays like an
episode this plays like a once a week
show you would watch yeah absolutely
because there's they're so dense there's
so much to absorb and then even with i
feel like if i'm binging and i'm like
what
more more time in the past because when
when anna first said that
at the early on she's like and i keep it
into you i thought it was she was just a
thing she said
i didn't think it was an actual like oh
they've been meeting up with each other
yeah i've been to each other and
separated back when i heard it i'm like
for the second time meeting you guys
one especially with as many illusions as
there were to directly the previous
episode it gives it this more serialized
feeling in the moment so then when you
get that piece of information you're
like oh that's right do you have so much
more history than we have been privy to
yeah i think what's really great about
the way they the way they shoot this
series is like a lot of it feel i don't
know what's green screen a lot of it
feels like just pure on location it
reminds me of
uh like lord of the rings because they
they go on so many different adventures
through all kinds of like beautiful
locations
and it really seems like they're putting
their actors through
a lot of walking they have to do
a lot of physicality that they have to
endure
and the the shots they get when they're
cutting around like multiple story lines
and just the amount of sets here
it
it still it still feels so drawn in by
it and uh
yeah i thought it was beautiful are
there are there is there a lore of
dragons being able to take human form
that i have never heard ah
you know it sounds vaguely stupid i wish
they kind of dived into it a bit yeah
yeah
yeah um it sounds vaguely familiar to me
in the sort of hodgepodge of mythologies
in the back of my mind but i don't
remember if it's like part of classic
dragon lore like their love of treasure
yeah or something like that but i i feel
like it's a thing that's happened or i
mean you know you have at least dragons
and other stories that speak and that
sort of can communicate directly and
aren't as you know the same thing not
quite it's not a smaug
this guy's got like the full-on benefits
of both worlds it seems like
it's nice you got both reveals in one a
green dragon and a gold dragon yeah and
he must be the mutation he's a mutation
they're talking about right a human
being or see a dragon first
then human or human first then dragon
that's a great question probably the
former probably but who knows
either way it's great stuff and this
whole thing with yennefer
and uh and and uh uh you know whatever
that [ __ ] guy's name is
gary
gerald the help gary of the river
the whole thing with jennifer and geralt
their chemistry is so solid and i love
how as the show has been progressing
you just watch this man
this witcher progressively become more
vulnerable this feels like the all is
lost moment of the character's
arc of the man who's
finding love he's finding this he's
finding vulnerability within himself
and she's also finding the connection
and her all her life she's been taught
not to trust
and i think the way they handle the
story line of i'm sure it's like in a
book or some [ __ ] but the way they
handle the story line of yennefer
dealing with um
wanting
a baby you know that could seem like a a
trope that i could see pissing people
off
you know i've seen avengers age of
ultron yeah
women are not just mothers yeah yeah
but the way they the way they build the
context around it i think is strong of
like i really love that line that she
says when she says uh
they took away my choice
and i want my choice back i know i get
it uh
i do like the other day the internet was
out
and
they were like well cover you for the
day you didn't have internet and i was
like thanks spectrum
and then they sent me a text message
saying that
well because your outage was not more
than four hours we can't pay you the ten
dollars for the day
and i was
furious and i called them and i said our
internet was out
for almost 24 full hours
and you're robbing me of
my ten dollars
that i'm owed
so jennifer and i are like we're in sync
man we're in sync it's just like having
your uterus or i was very much uh i very
much get it yeah yeah i'm trying to say
that like you know as men it's important
we learn to identify draw from our own
personal experiences
so we
can know what it's like to you know we
can somehow we can never fully
understand but there's ways we can
empathize as men dude i feel like you
are enlightening me just through this
whole experience oh i got more please
let me let me take some notes here hold
on that story's a 7-eleven it went wrong
bunch of stuff
really suffered i know what it's like
dude
verizon 10 women bills i've really
struggled with this yeah
yes
yeah that um
that that storyline is is really
powerful and i love how
the way they paint it
with
such a great gray surrounding the
context i was kind of a little bit
surprised by how quick she was like this
stuff we're done yeah freaking gin magic
bye
uh because all the experiences they went
went along with alone on the mountain
but a lot of it seems more than just
whatever they're laying down in you know
text
of surface stuff
of you know
gin magic uh that's the only reason you
know we're we're drawn together oh you
just want a baby like the way they're
fighting with one another
a lot of it
really seems to come down to the the
core of
neither one of them is comfortable truly
being vulnerable and neither one of them
is comfortable really trusting others
they're sabotaging yeah that's what it
is it's just that's all it is it's just
high school [ __ ]
yeah grow up
[Laughter]
no i mean i root for them i love them
together i absolutely do too and and
yeah i mean i think there was so much
going well for them that i felt like
another shoe had to drop but i thought
they orchestrated the drama of that well
and yeah
it's like they're able to make you
really feel
and see through
her perspective like think into episodes
back when they're actually performing
the procedure and they pull it out you
know you're like wow that is
incredibly horrific and you're locked
into her perspective for that whole
thing so more even than the idea that
she wants to be a mother or have a baby
and fill that particular role it seems
like she wants to be complete and whole
for real
and i think there's a lot to that and
just their chemistry together the way
they play off each other is just so
exquisite a lot of the time and yeah
this was a fun kind of way to put them
it's like the last one was building up
to like oh man you know i can't believe
they're gonna meet finally and this was
like now they're gonna they're stuck in
a situation together for a lot of it and
yet they still manage to occupy their
own plane outside of it even though they
are also quite significant to what's
really going on in that situation yeah i
think they build a good job on like this
this plot of going up the mountain to
fight the dragon it could have just been
you know what crazy things they're
encountering along the way more of like
the creatures like when that knife was a
dick
yeah the shitty the way
like it seemed like they could have just
done more of that made it more about
peril and they didn't make it about that
i really respected it they still made it
character driven
and relationship building you know like
when they're in the tent jennifer and
geralt i kind of forgot about this whole
like going on a mountain thing i was so
engrossed in that
and i think henry cavill does such a
great job because he has to find the
right pitch of vulnerability you can't
go too soft too fast you know yeah okay
no time to dye this yeah
can't wolverine x-men the last stand
yeah you know if you go if you go you
gotta be able to you know there's times
he gets really like really soft with her
um but you have to hit the right pitch
or else it becomes like overkill with
the vulnerability you know and that's
what helps keep it human and like in
their quieter moments uh
and you know the chemistry is strong
because a lot of time i'd be like what
the hell we didn't see any other times i
met up yeah [ __ ]
but here like no actually now that i'm
leaving i'm learning it right now and i
really believe it in the moment yeah
yeah absolutely and the way they're
calling her yen too
yeah yeah and it's like the in the way
and we saw the seeds of that in the last
episode but like the way that he seems
to like truly at least in his
performance the way it comes across like
he truly is concerned for her and seems
to truly care for her well-being and
that's like a very distinct flavor
i feel like among all the different
characters and not to say that there are
other characters who don't care about
others sure sure but yeah there's like
there's such a piercing thing whenever
he's trying to cut through and be like
no please i'm not trying to you know
manipulate you or whatever i'm just
trying to look out for your well-being
and i love that whole thing about them
comparing their positions as mage and
witcher and the sort of things that are
saddled on you
when people decide that's what your fate
ought to be
uh
yeah it's just a lot of like really i
loved how you got like a fun ensemble
piece with like a lot of colorful
characters and people to be suspicious
of but you also got like a really
intimate and fleshed and what felt like
you know like a fully rounded you know
you know one-on-one story between them
true true and then by the end i just
broke my heart when he goes off on
yaskir like yeah man you're grieving go
through the blame game
yeah that's all his favorite great
material for asking dude he's gonna
write the best breakup album about
geralt
about geralt breaking up with yen carol
breaking up with the oscar everyone
maybe when siri finally meets up with
them
um what's her name siri
really yeah cyrilla
siri siri for short cersei's the other
ones from eternals and the game of
thrones yes okay so
yeah when siri finally meets up with
them it's going to be yes you're just
going to be like fat and old no
never i can't i don't want to toss a hot
dog to your wish
tossing
early bird discounts for your witcher
yeah
yeah i love his performance man he
brings like such natural levity uh to
all of it and he's really good at at
doing that thing where he's just
he it doesn't feel like dialogue when
he's just talking and he's the only one
talking and he's just like noticing
things and making in comments and like
he's really good at those spiels
uh
yeah i love the locations and i'll i'll
say this that i like i i think that with
siri
and dara the storyline that we've been
checking him with there
while i'm interested in it and while i
thought there was a lot of great tension
they pulled uh when you know the mouse
cat
and them were traveling through the
woods and all that jazz i do feel that
because like don't get me wrong i like
it and i do think it's
gorgeous to behold and i and i love
i love their use of
handling snowy environments they tend to
make it like a horror movie whenever
they're you're capturing story lines
here in the snow
they capture the atmosphere a lot i
think the show's just generally really
good at that
i do find the character development it
feels like so much more plot driven
because we barely check in with them and
the scenes are short yeah that's what i
mean the scenes are short
um
shorter comparatively they're shorter
comparatively you don't they don't get
as much screen time and it feels like
mainly just plot
and i i feel like a lack of character
development and it's sort of been
feeling that way for me with them for
the past few episodes
yeah so it is something i'm starting to
crave and uh knowing this show
because by the time i was that whole
thing with like dara and and and siri
like yeah you become i don't like you
anymore princess but yeah people the
danger lady and uh
you know like i like i like i like them
i do i i'm not just saying that like i
like them i like dara but
you know i wasn't like oh man
well yeah wow
in a way that is pretty kind of standard
like you can kind of see which direction
it's going i really like this stuff
where they're finally
sort of chipping away the veneer of the
fake mouse second all that stuff true
true and yeah i thought those moments
were pretty good but i'd agree it's it's
it's like they're they're
serviceable in the times that we cut
back to them and yeah i'm like i'm
interested but i'm also waiting to feel
like i really am getting to know siri or
or her perspective and i thought brookie
long could do that i thought those
characters might serve to open her up a
little bit but yeah it seems like so
much of it is just on the run
we're on the run yeah you know
uh but they capture a good mood there
there's a lot of surrounding context to
it that i really appreciate and the
performances are still good i do crave a
little bit more
just general scene work i guess yeah and
it seems like they can handle it i mean
her performance especially series is is
solid it's solid yeah and when she has
that that's true that's fantastic and
when she has to like do those like
silent reaction moments i'm like yeah
you know she's she's selling me on these
things so i don't think it's they're not
giving her material because they don't
think she can handle it or something but
i'd agree with that but yeah guys this
is an amazing show i i am genuinely
loving it foreign always look forward to
it and uh yeah getting this like band of
misfits to go under adventure but
they're no one you could really trust i
love those kind of story lines in
general help the dorms come back
[Music]
angry dwarfs
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button keep a lookout for our next
episode of witcher that might come out
earlier too since we gotta play catch up
before s2 rolls around
patriot of the day shout out
lance
door i don't know you
anymore
i'm beginning to feel like you think
it's a chore to talk with us
i don't know why but i find it a little
suss
because here's the thing we have arrived
upon christmas
and yet
i don't feel like you really miss us
now you're distracting me oh sorry i
lost it i lost the room oh no you're the
rhythm i was doing it but you got to
give him
a good
uh circumcision circumcision
cause a schism
between him and his
women there you do a poetry show john
someone's doing poem you just start
beatboxing
this would be so much better as a rap
that's right man i just wanna yeah i'm
trying to hype everyone up
lance
listen dude if i was to go up a mountain
with anyone to be you because you're a
freaking firefighter man you're the guy
who would be the one to help carry me
along such a
perilous trek in my life you'd be handy
you know how to use all the right tools
if anyone was injured you come in with
the right repairing body
part [ __ ] knowledge you're searching
right that's what you do
eric body part [ __ ] knowledge yeah dude
that's how that's what they qualify you
as being a firefighter and i don't even
know if you're married right now or what
the hell is going on with that you were
engaged for what i felt like forever are
you married are you happy you gotta have
that 10-year engagement before you make
it a fish i miss you dude
say hi to your mom for me
say hi to your wife or fiance or
ex-girlfriend i don't know what she is
to you now and say hi to your baby or
your
former child uh you know whatever that
position your future child was it
biological it was adopted
was it made
in a loud laugh
a box of scraps
anyway merry christmas lance
[Music]